live just going to do a very short
stream here um have to head to the gym
in a bit I'll get back on my normal
schedule just been messed up with
Christmas and
all hey how's it going
man I owe you some uh
integration assistance I presume with
the
optimizer uh where is this
thing
39 all right so we'll comment this for
now because Captain says it needs to be
commented
150k yeah this is too slow uh let's
figure out what's wrong with this
thing
so I think he messed with this ve a
whole bunch right yeah look he messed
with back a whole
arcs
uh I'm confused as to what he did
here he made like a custom version of
our trainer
okay so he does have
multiprocessing okay so I got to just
see what the heck is going on here
because he's got some
ARS he's got zero copy set to
True 8 m eight workers B size of
okay so that doesn't seem to make a
difference if anything that's slower
help so the m is definitely just too
damn slow at the moment we'll figure
that out
um so his 88 settings are kind of fine
then by
default
interesting wait num drones num
um hang on maybe this is not what I
think it
is and 15 okay hopefully he's on in time
so num
256 okay he took my advice correctly I
believe
CNN it could just be this map CNN to be
fair
stri well that's
Jank five at Stride two does that even
make
sense I think you'd want this at Stride
three and and then you can't do this at
Stride two either that doesn't
help I think the most likely thing is is
just his OBS are too damn
fine it actually doesn't have any of the
normal errors in
channels what's
this
32 yeah so he's already cut this
down quite a
lot
I it's hard to
see he's messed with all the training
harness 230k that's not
huge it's pretty small
still maybe as many batches are the
wrong
size let me
see there's no config though he just
there we
go 270
300 yeah he's just above the there's a
point at which the GPU is just like no
that's too much data
let's just double check to make
sure this isn't
32 oops this will be good for
him what El
else
Amo see now I have to actually go look
at my parameters from one of my runs
because I got to make sure he didn't
mess anything
oh no wait store yeah no he's got it
right never
mind this is true by default
matter made that kind of
long learning rate a Neal yep
he mess with the grad
you shouldn't need
this but you know fair
enough B size no more for Ms zero
copy cool so now
okay 260 20% time lost to the
environment right
oh this is
[Music]
okay so that should have helped so why
didn't
it that should have helped
massively let me get my second term
window up
question
mark did not use this
here okay so this is now
good this is 4096
yeah so that should be massively faster
so what happened
17% 10
4 for is 31%
interestingly that seems not to make a
difference I guess the policy is a
little bit
bigger also the data is just way
larger
uh Hey Spencer how's it going
here not really code review just helping
Captain with his his environment he's
stuck on some
stuff I'm looking for where he's leaking
perf and
stuff to start with
probably going to mostly then be the the
com architector here
no apparently
not oh no that is
faster I think it's mostly the map but
let's take a look
this net is like both too large and too
small at the same time it's weird
I think the com is probably just
slow so let me think if I were to do
this for him
correctly I don't know if you're going
to be able to do it with 7 by seven is
the
okay so this
is 21 so if I did stride
four so that would be like to
here then one
sketchy yeah doesn't fit
um I think 7 by seven like 7 by S conss
are just massive as
helps let me see you only have 32
channels to begin with
Am I Wrong maybe it's not even the map
CNN hold on
hey captain we're at
300K um I'm trying to figure
out if your com is slow or what because
this is like
lstm output size encoder output
size I guess this is just encoder output
size yeah I'm looking um so Captain the
first there was only you actually did
pretty much everything correctly um the
only big error that you had was uh you
had six 64,000 mini batch size that is
too big when you when the mini batch
size like you get better and better curf
up to a threshold and then it just
catastrophically drops off um so 32k is
usually the max for policies this size
is that a learning per thing it's a
hardware thing it's just straight up
that the GPU like you just shove too
much data per batch into the GPU
comp yeah so without the com you see
this thing would be like 6 700,000 it
looks like because look at the 41% M
no don't have compile
on nural MMO gets 500k without
compile yeah so right here it's the
policy I'm trying to think what to do
for you here
because you just have too big of
a of a field
here I mean I don't want to go down to
16 channels but
like I was fiddling with the bigger
receptive field maybe but that's also
kind of
sketchy I did mess with the stride to
put that up to three
speed's less of a concern well I can't
run experiments if it's slow but I guess
I've gotten it to be a little
faster okay so let's see you got one V
the link
okay we'll do a short session on this
now hopefully I will find something
before I go to gym if not I will go back
uh later okay so this
is oh okay sure whatever you just turn
this back on so the funny thing with
this thing that you just did
here right like cost performance you can
literally just do that like this created
timestamp this just goes time process
and this is a parito curve
yeah I'm
aware we didn't bother though because um
parito front you can get just from The
Sweep it's like so
silly and I'm sure it's got some
degenerate
parameters is this all you're sweeping
here
no you
have you're sweeping a ton of
stuff okay yeah you're throwing like
everything in
there the
hardcoded cuz I see all the these
observations
especially what happens if I just run
this stuff track still
this is a very this is a silly graph
right here
okay so you
have all your logging in here
let's see what let's see what is in the
do
H all right
how much how much time have you spent
looking at your
observations like as they're going into
the
compute reward based off of how much
projectile
yeah okay
so even without looking at observations
and stuff
um this thing is like numerically
horribly horribly unstable
out yeah you're just getting wrecked
numerically
here
okay even track
folks your observations are normed
reasonably enough
okay so value loss actually doesn't go
nuts it's clip fraction
oh this could very well be the
uh this is continuous actions
right or is this discr right now